Mars.
I always
wonder what it would be like to live there
And to build there.
What would it feel like to look out the window
and see an alien landscape
millions and millions of miles away
from everything we know.
Although the exact timeline is unclear.
We're definitely planning
for a new life on Mars
and we're putting a lot of money into it.
NASA has plans to send their first human
missions sometime in 2030,
SpaceX by 2029, and also establish
a city of 1 million by 2050.
The Emirates plans to build
a human settlement by the year 2117,
although there are still a lot
of variables and unknowns
in the last couple of years,
we found potential water , they found
Organic molecules hinting to signs of life
and technology is accelerating
at an insane rate.
This video
sponsored and brainstormed with Milanote
More on them later in this video.
The Kardashev scale is a method of
assessing the technological capabilities
of a civilization
based on the amount of energy it can use
and manipulate.
A Type one civilization has full control
over all of our energy sources.
We're currently at type 0.72,
but we are on track to reaching type one.
And once we get there,
according to Kardashev,
we're going to have such a profound
understanding of science and technology.
We're going to be able to manipulate
matter and energy on a molecular level.
We're going to have control over the water
patterns,
and we're even going to be able
to colonize other planets.
So maybe it's just a matter of time
that humans start to expand
beyond our planet.
But what kind of conditions do
we need to build for humans
to really live there and not just survive?
And is our species even ready for this?
Right now, the focus
for the next couple of decades is getting
the first few astronauts to live there
for an extended period of time.
But I think
once that mission is successful, it's
really a matter of time
until we get the first pioneers
who are the selected test group who's
going to continue to do research on Mars,
and the first settlers, the first Mars
community to permanently live there.
And one day
we will have a human colony on Mars.
They'll probably think and maybe
even look very different from us.
Each of these categories of people
are going to have a very different
experience of Mars depending
on the technical apparatus of that time.
And we're still quite a ways away
from being able to modify the Martian
atmosphere and be able to experience Mars
as we currently live on Earth.
Right now, we're in this very first stage.
But this is a really critical point
because once we get past this mark,
where we're not just surviving
but thriving on Mars, it's going
to open the doors to a whole new frontier
and becoming a multi-planet species
where we could feel confident
about creating
new habitats wherever we go.
There
have been lots of different proposals
for habitation on Mars,
but it seems like we are leaning
towards a construction method
that's a combination of prefabrication
and 3D printing
using the local material on Mars.
So in 2019, NASA held a competition
to design a 3D printed habitat on Mars
to house four astronauts
for the time span of a year.
They were given a set
of functional requirements like a lab,
a kitchen, a rec room, and 1000
square feet of living space,
all designed for the astronauts
to conduct research while living there.
If these habitats prove to be successful,
these modules should be easily replicable
for further expansion.
Each of these proposals
use a phased strategy
where they send autonomous machines
to first harvest
the raw Martian materials,
and then they create a building
material using the Martian soil
and other composites.
And then they 3D print
the initial framework
for the habitat
before the astronauts actually get there.
Once this is built,
the outfit, the interior, either
through an inflatable structure
or any other prefabricated components
that come together
on the inside of the shell.
To make this video, we looked at hundreds
of articles and videos, and we use Milanote
to organize all of our research
into something a little bit more coherent.
Milanote is extremely intuitive with lots
of templates that you can choose from.
And for us, having a visual mind
map like this
always helps us make connections
that we didn't see before.
You can very easily drag and drop images,
and my favorite part is how it converts
links into thumbnails.
So you don't ever need to download things.
All of this is on the cloud
so you can share it
with other people and it's completely free
with no time limits.
So you can sign up using the link
in the description.
I'm actually really curious
how you guys use it, so if you've tried
it, let me know in the comments.
You can't do
this on Mars.
Keep your legs straight.
This is misison control Houston
3 hours and 26 minutes
into the space walk byt Cassada and Rubio
An astronaut has to deal
with a huge amount of problems on Mars,
like radiation,
massive temperature changes, exposure
to dust and other contaminants, changes
in the nervous system.
There's lower gravity,
which can cause what they call
a puffy face chicken legs syndrome.
Yes, that's what the that's what
it's actually called chicken leg syndrome.
And of course, you're really far away
from anything and everything,
including food,
materials, hospitals and equipment.
Even if everything goes perfectly
with the engineering
and the astronauts are perfectly trained
physically,
the mission could still fail
due to the human factor
isolation, being far away from home,
living in a confined, high stress
environment, it could lead to depression
and behavioral changes.
I mean, we really
saw this during COVID, right?
There are several places on
Earth that share similarities
with the red planet.
In fact, some of them are used
as training grounds for astronauts.
But these aren't necessarily
the best representation
of how people are actually
going to live there, because Mars doesn't
really have a living surface with zero
air pressure.
Mars is essentially a vacuum.
You just can't survive without a suit.
You would black out in like 20 seconds,
and if you tried breathing,
your lungs would rupture
and you would die within minutes.
In fact,
even the harshest environment on Earth
is still going to feel like
heaven compared to Mars.
But I think there's
a few manmade environments that do have
some similarities to living on Mars.
The structure of a lighthouse
is a series of interconnected components
with a specific function
controlled by the inhabitants.
Your everyday life and duties
are entangled with the structure
as long as you live there.
In some ways,
you become a part of the lighthouse,
but you can still go out and take
fresh air and experience
the environment outside the lighthouse.
What happens
if you take the concept of a lighthouse
to the extreme.
just like on a mars habitat
People in a submarine work together
towards completing a mission that could
last months.
Each person has a very specific job
and they have to work together to succeed.
And they do this while crammed inside
a pressurized steel hull
with very little personal space.
So the level of pressure
get it?
is both physical and psychological.
In each of these self-contained
conditions, there's a real profound
connection between the inhabitants
and the places they live
because it can determine
whether you live or die.
The most important
part of the Martian habitat
is the shell that protects
from radiation and the hostile climate.
So a lot of these designs free a cave
like condition.
There are some examples of troglodyte
settlements like the Matamata underground
houses and Tunisia, Africa,
which uses the Earth's mass
to protect themselves from the heat
and the windstorms.
But even in the settlements,
you still have access to the outdoors.
This is also going to be
the very first time that humans are going
to be living in complete disconnect
from the physical environment.
So the way that they shell mediates
the connection to the outside
environment is really important,
not just for physical safety
but also for a psychological connection
to the Martian environment.
The project KAHN-YATES
it's designed with multiple glazed opening
and the is organized over three stories
so you can get a wide
array of different views
into the outside environment.
You also have
these more dome shaped designs,
which are a little bit more common,
which has one or two fixed views.
The Shell also affects
the functional organization and movement
within the habitat.
You'll see
lots of different forms in the design,
but you can kind of divide them into two
distinct categories
a vertical layout and a horizontal layout
Within the horizontal Layout
there's designs that separated
all of the functions
into their distinct pods,
and there's ones that's consolidated
all of the functions into one single pod.
If you're looking at courtyard typologies
as a way to create social interaction,
maybe an organization like this
makes a little bit more sense.
These are probably the most efficient
structures in terms of applicability
because you can create more
and you can connect more pods.
But if it were me,
my mental health would deteriorate
real fast in these types of arrangements.
One, because they're highly,
highly monotonous
and you can see the same spaces.
and same walls from all different views.
Two There's very little separation
between functions.
According to Edward T Hall,
we all have a spatial dimension
that determines our relationship
to each other and to our surroundings.
When these dimensions are disrupted,
either by other people or by poor design.
You can have really serious
psychological impacts.
And he calls this idea proxemics
In his book, The Hidden Dimension.
He talks about a crowding experiment
in Norway,
where they took a group of 48 rats
and put them in an indoor environment.
They were given everything they needed
except for personal space.
There was a quick population boom,
followed by such a severe psychological
and behavioral disruption that
it eventually led to their extinction.
He called these behavioral sinks.
It distorted their behavior,
everything from sex nest building,
birth territoriality,
and a lot of the rats had tumors
and enlarged kidneys and enlarged livers,
all of which are signs of extreme stress.
The crowding led
to a pathological behavior in the rats.
And although humans have,
for the most part, developed
the level of cognitive sophistication
that makes us think before we act.
The limbic system,
which is a part of the brain
that controls our emotional processing
and motivation, is still one of
the oldest parts of the brain, and it has
a direct connection to the brainstem.
So our reactions and behaviors are still
very influenced by our instincts.
And just like animals,
we still have an instinctive
spatial dimension that influences
how we interact in different environments.
Even if we have physical separations
or the most advanced
virtual reality technology.
We still need to think
about these invisible dimensions
as extensions of our bodies,
and not just that
these invisible dimensions are also based on things like cultural background
and the nature of the relationship between the people.
There's an example in the book Japanese walls versus
German walls. In Japanese culture
for a really long time.
They've used paper walls and paper doors,
so Japanese people can selectively
filter out auditory information
and they speak more softly
while German people
they need really thick, soundproof
walls, otherwise they'd feel intruded on
in loud atmospheres.
If we want to create
an enclosed environment
where we try to avoid conflict
as much as possible, we really need
to consider these invisible dimensions
and not just
the performance.
These two proposals divide the functions
vertically, and these ones
divide the functions into individual pods.
The horizontal layout definitely provides
more separation.
In  X House, the sleeping area is the same pod
as the lab, which connects the lab
and the gym in the other pod.
And there's another pod for the kitchen.
And the two vertical proposals
have all the functions
separated into different
but interconnected floors.
Comparing the two layouts, my preference
would definitely be the vertical one.
And my reason is because
even in the most technical environments,
in fact, especially in the most technical
and rigorous environments,
I think you need a sense
of variability and surprise,
something that's not planned.
These people are going to be living
in the same environments,
doing the same thing with the same people,
eating the same friggin food
every single day for a year.
Everything is scheduled,
everything is planned,
and there is absolutely no surprise.
This type of arrangement
means that if I want to go to the kitchen,
I go to the kitchen.
If I want to go to the lab,
I'll go this way and I'll go to the lab.
It's really efficient
and it's really purposeful.
But I think in such a high stress
environment, you need a little bit of space to roam
without purpose,
even if it's like 1% of the time.
With this vertical layout,
if you want to get to the lab,
you have to get past the garden
and the kitchen.
And in those moments
you might run into another crew
or you might find some other activity.
That's going on.
And the result is
you don't just get a variety
in interactions,
but also a variety in experiences as well.
You get a sense of scale and hierarchy
and a sense of surprise.
Instead of having everything visible
in your face.
Environments like this creates a sense
of curiosity and it creates atmosphere.
The Kahn Yates
project also has a vertical organization,
but in this case it incorporates
a garden at the ground level
that each of the floors
can look down onto.
One of the competitions program
requirements was a garden,
and a lot of these other projects provided
a highly efficient hydroponics garden.
But again,
I really like how this design creates
an informal, unplanned space,
while also dual functioning as a garden.
There's concern
messaging around these explorations.
We need to design for people to thrive,
not just survive.
And of course, the safety and efficiency
of these habitats are very,
very important.
They're going to form the basis
for our attitude towards
inhabiting foreign landscapes.
So I think it's some of these
intangible qualities,
even though they're hard to quantify,
they can really make the difference
between a research mission
and a new and exciting vision
for the future.